Je peux les voir Je pouvais sentir la présence
juste derrière moi
[Musique]
Essayer de bouger ma tête d'un côté à l'autre Je
ne pouvais tout simplement pas bouger Je veux bouger
J'essaie de bouger et je ne peux absolument pas être
terrifié Mon corps était paralysé
c'était tellement fort dans la pièce qu'il est devenu rouge
et j'avais l'impression que quelque chose venait
après moi oh non je n'ai pas l'impression que quelqu'un
allait m'attraper si je crie complètement
abattu Je n'avais aucune idée de ce qui se passait,
ils ne faisaient que bouger des ombres  et ça
me regarde, ils étaient tous en train de tourner Je
reste debout toute la nuit en essayant que ma montre soit
pire que comme dans les films
[Applaudissements]